I think any time you're making fun of  powerful people that's a good thing I  think we need to we need to uh the  challenge is and the reverse is true  right the powerful people who want to  shut you down that's because they're  insecure yeah but but but I think you  know I think the world wants to see you  know a what becomes a problem is when  SNL only targets one side that's when  it's kind of like so if you do both  sides I'm all in if you do one side  that's the part where some people are  like if Sasha Baron Cohen did that same  thing to both sides of the aisle I  guarantee everybody would go watch it  but when he does it only to one side  something like yeah you don't I don't  want to see it because you're not doing  the hypocrisy on the other side